um yesterday i posted on twitter  um the bosses of itv are coming in what  would you like me to  ask them i could various suggestions  some serious some less so but i thought  this one was very interesting from  um somebody called henry warren um  and he says this could you please ask  them why they're not turning on  the subtitles by default on children's  tv  it's been shown to double literacy  uh youtube which you mentioned in  caroline already  do it um kids do youtube kids do it  and the bbc are also now embracing this  why i apologize for my tax tale why and  why are you not doing this by default  rocco could you kill them  ninety percent of them fci tv  that's a guaranteed  ninety percent of uh citv conspiracy  i just can i just say i just do that to  your publishing people  appearing before us it's particularly  effective with captain ministers  very awesome i'll have another game